اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من وسط قطاع غزه
اهلا بكم القسام تنشر مشاهد لما قالت انه
استهداف لدبابات واليات اسرائيليه في
مدينه غزه وتظهر فيها ملابس عسكريه لعدد
من الجنود الاسرائيليين وقلادات
ومعداتهم كما اعلنت الاجهاز على سته جنود
اسرائيليين من المسافه الصفر في منطقه جحر
الدي في حين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل
ثلاثه ضباط وجنود في المعارك شمال غزه
ليرتفع عدد قتلاه اليوم الى خمسه مدير
المستشفيات في قطاع غزه يعلن اجلاء 31 من
الاطفال الخدج من مستشفى الشفاء وبيان
اممي يصف المستشفى بمنطقه موت عقب جوله
لمنظمه الصحه ومنظمات امميه اخرى فيه في
حين قالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان الاحتلال
يرتكب المزيد من المجازر في القطاع لتحقيق
حلمه في التهجير القصري للسكان اما على
الصعيد الدبلوماسي رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري يقول انه اكثر ثقه
باقتراب التوصل لاتفاق بشان المحتجزين
ويطالب اسرائيل بالالتزام بقرار مجلس
الامن وقف الحرب وفتح ممرات انسانيه بغزه
في حين دعا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي الى هدن انسانيه فوريه
مستدامه مؤكدا ان حل الدولتين هو الامثل
قيادي بجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين يقول
للجزيره انهم اقتادوا سفينه اسرائيليه
لشواطئ اليمن نصره للمظلومين بغزه بحسب
قوله من جانبه قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
اختطاف السفينه امر خطير عالميا مضيفا ان
السفينه المختطفه غادرت تركيا الى الهند
بطاقم مدني ولم يكن على متنها اسرائيليون
وهي ليست اسرائيلي
تحقيق اولي للشرطه الاسرائيليه بشان احداث
السابع من اكتوبر يشير الى ان طائره حربيه
اسرائيليه قصفت على ما يبدو اسرائيليين
قرب رعيم بغلاف غزه اثناء محاوله استهداف
مسلحين وكبير مستشاري نتنياهو يؤكد خفض
الارقام الرسميه بشان قتل الهجوم بعد
اكتشاف جثث متفحمه لم تكن لاسرائيل بل
لافراد من
القسام الى
اللقاء